hey what's up guys my name is Jenna
welcome to episode 62 of game
programming so it has been a while I
realize a long time no see
but I've been really busy and basically
the way that I wanted to do game
programming episodes from now on is when
I have time okay so if I have like an
extra hour or something in my week then
I'll try and knock down one or two and
we'll see what happens but um obviously
University comes first and and yeah but
you know you know that doesn't mean that
I'm not gonna be making videos it's just
gonna mean that you know I'm gonna make
them when I have time
not on the schedule but I'll still try
and knock down maybe two or three a week
okay
so basically we ended kind of here and
we've kind of wanted to scent it's just
to set a location a spawn location for
our player yeah and one thing I might do
actually I've been thinking about this
for a while is actually reducing this
bright size of this player down to UM
one tile some of the words at the moment
he's like 32 by 32 I might bring him
down at 16 by 16 so he matches one tile
or something like that so that's a
possibility but yeah so we had this um
was Tyra right so if I open if I come
over here and I open I say yeah I'm just
fine my okay Swain so you know in our
rain directory if we hit up resources
levels and spawn and let's just open it
with actually probably 70 like that we
have this little teal tile here now one
thing that we kind of wanted to do
initially was scan this and set that as
a spawn location I decided against that
though because that's not really very
practical at all because the thing is
like at the moment we know that's gonna
be wood behind it but we don't always
know that and then there's also the fact
that you know why why I said it in that
it's all I saw like the spawn like is
gonna change or anything
first particular level and it might you
know in the future if we want to return
to this form level it might remember
what we're where we were last in this
one level as well so it's just not
really practical to have a fixed spawn
location in the actual level file so I'm
going to open this in paint on that
most gonna get rid of it and one other
thing that I'm going to do before I get
rid of it it actually check out the
coordinates of Horace ass so if I just
hold my mouse over and then I'll just
oops
select like the pencil tool you can see
over here that it actually says the
coordinates so it says it is at 19 comma
62 so I'm scared not knowing bad and
type in 1962 so don't forget and that's
gonna be where we spawn out and that's
it again so you can say write that in
1962 right yeah we can we can just right
over that just like that save it okay
and now it should be good to go
so there's a few different ways of
handling this again I guess it depends
on all you want to do but one of the
ways that I like handling it personally
is I like creating stuff called
basically like a helper class kind of
thing so I'm over here in level I'm I am
just putting a level probably in level
yeah I'll create a new class and I'll
coldest something like tile coordinate
okay literally that's all it's gonna be
and this is going to be a very simple
class i this is just me like I just like
organizing things and in fact we might
get we might just get rid of that that
for now and basically all this is gonna
do right this is gonna have two
variables x and y all right make sure
they're integers and what we can access
from this tile coordinate is basically
public tile coordinate so we're just
gonna have a constructor and it's gonna
have X&Y all right and then all we can
all we have to do here really just say
this dot x equals x there's still y
equals y and then if we want to access
it all right we can make a bunch of
methods like public int you know let's
just say X all right and that will
simply return X and it'll be a bit bit
bit more complicated in a minute but
public in Y and that will return Y and
public in
XY maybe and it might be an array so
what this might be is and you'll see
you'll see what this isn't in that but
looks like it's been a while since I've
actually programmed anything on anything
that you know in on this computer at
least so we'll return maybe a will
return let's just create a quick in
which we'll call it you know s ah maybe
for result and we'll set it equal to new
in two and then we'll set y 0 equal to X
1 equal to Y and then we'll respond that
will return it all right so that's one
way of doing it so I'll return both the
minion right um well school we do where
we return the actual tile coordinate but
I think we have to yes I don't know
that's probably it for now one thing
that we need to calculate though is you
know when we do set the tile coordinate
we want we just want to set the
coordinates on other words our
coordinate right now is 1962 now
remember what the size of tiles is it
took the size of the tiles is um 16
right so for now all right this is it it
probably won't change throughout again
that's one thing I want to point out as
well
tiles probably won't change like the
size of child's doesn't like some levels
of 32 sized tiles so levels will have
eight sized tiles they'll all have 16
size tiles so we don't have to worry
about this but what we what we should
have is a private final and so make sure
that it's a constant base plate and
we'll call it tile size and also that
equal to 16 and all we need to do here
is say that this dot x equals x times
tile size so in other words that will
basically just find the size for us and
then that should pretty much work out
wonderfully so an example of this can be
in the play class so when we actually do
set our x and y and we don't at the
moment right we set this at x equal to x
that's sort of our spawn location and
what I'll probably do maybe next episode
is actually all about setting spawn
locations and how would it
with that I just wanted to spend today's
episode on the tail cord in a class just
because I'm yeah like people usually
don't think of doing this and it's
really useful like I love it so I
thought I'd just share that with you
guys cool story bro alright okay so
let's see how I said okay so how does it
how it cat so let's chose out so
currently the player gets set in x and y
like that as cool well we could do that
instead is um this was something I was
working on actually earlier so here it
is for now but um
okay wait so we don't actually set and
all right at least don't work
yeah okay so we've got another
constructor here in playoff which deals
with in X Nina why not recess the
location so what we could do here is we
could simply say that you know player
equals new player and we've got two
coordinates to fill out we could just
say that for example tile coordinate
player spawn all right place form equals
new tile coordinate and then we'll say
that maybe you know 1962 right that's
what I wanted to realize and then what
we can say here is that it's simply
player spawn dot X and that's going to
be player spawn del Y and that's it and
then that should work right so if we
launch our game we can say that we
actually spawn there and you know it
just helps us kind of organize it
because we um you know it's just 1962
and then if we have to use it again then
we can simply for referencing that class
and if you want to create another one
when we can so it's like we're sort of
we've created a system to deal with tile
coordinates which is very useful all the
names kind of long tail coordinate but
um yeah so that's kind of how that works
and it's very useful and you'll find
we'll be using this type of classes
these types of classes very often in the
future of this game but basically that's
what Alcona does and next time we're
going to talk about actually
implementing applies more system so that
we don't have to you know have this
whole constructor thing
actually set them natively basically so
yeah that's it episode 62 what if I
don't see you guys next time data
you